c'est
dans les librairies ça doit les prix
sont à la hausse oui de régulièrement le
depuis quelques mois il ya des petites
augmentations je te vois beaucoup en ce
moment sur les livres de poche ça peut
augmenter d'un dollar ou 2 cette
inflation pourrait s'accentuer car le
plus important est primeur de livres au
canada marque qui imprima a envoyé mardi
une note à ses clients indiquant que le
prix du papier d'édition gré près de 6 à
9% dès le 12 février que plus de
en librairie ça pourrait se traduire par
une augmentation du prix d'environ 5% en
2022 dans certains cas ça veut dire
aussi minime dans d'autres cas des
hausses plus marqué mais en général on
peut penser que le produit va augmenter
un petit peu par rapport à ce qu'on est
habitué parce que ça a été un produit
qui reste au même prix depuis presque
vingt ans le secteur du livre est en
pleine croissance en 2021 les ventes ont
augmenté de près de 16% par rapport à
2020 et les éditeurs ne veulent pas
freiner cet élan avec des prix trop
élevés mais un livre jeunesse que les
gens sont habitués à payer 19 95 la
capacité d'augmenter le prix très limité
on passe à 20 95 ou 21 95 mais c'est
tout on peut le vendre 26 95 le marché
suivre au pot parmi les produits
culturels il n'y a pas que le prix du
livre qui augmentera par exemple le
géant netflix a annoncé que le prix de
son forfait haute définition grimpera
d'environ 10% il est aussi le disque
vinyle le plastique et le papier sont
plus chers comme de plastique et du
plastique le vinyle est en utilise
beaucoup dans cette usine de pressage de
disques vinyles il ya une explosion des
coûts de production j'ai regardé des
chiffes l'année passée en janvier 2021
on payait notre plastique environ 1 $ 16
us la livre on est maintenant rendu à 2
et 6 us la livre janvier 2022 dont un
app store une augmentation 80% du prix
du plastique par ligne de retour dans
les librairies la légère hausse du prix
des romans mais qui est pas outre mesure
pour l'instant je pense à votre subtil
il ya des états qui vont en profiter il
ya des diffuseurs qui vont en profiter
mais c'est pas dans l'intérêt du milieu
de 2,3 en profiter en temps de pandémie
plusieurs grands lecteurs vous diront
qu'un bon livre
ça n'a pas de prix ici où il fait
déprimer radio canada montréal